(light music)
(typewriter typing)
- Maths underpins
everything in our universe,
so it impacts every corner of our society.
But over the past decade in particular,
the advances in computer technology
and the introduction of machine learning
and artificial intelligence
has been massive.
And we're only learning more and more
and building better and better systems.
And maths underpins all of that
and it's fundamental to
all of those systems.
And in fact, computer science
is inherently linear algebra,
so it's really foundational
to those scientific advances.
- One relatively recent example
that really inspired me
was the first real photo
that scientists were able
to capture of a black hole,
those mysterious remnants
of giant stars that lurk
all over the universe.
And it is the way the scientists
used creativity and math
to solve the problem
that was so fascinating.
You see, these black holes are do distant
that there is no single
telescope that is large enough
to be able to actually see them.
And the scientists came
up with this clever idea,
creating a network of small
telescopes distributed
all across the globe
that were synchronized
to capture and focus the
same object at the same time,
creating a giant virtual telescope.
Now, the aperture of this
giant virtual telescope
is nearly the same size as
the diameter of the Earth.
And with that in place,
the scientists and engineers
were able to capture
all the bits and pieces of data
and put it all together
into the first image
of a black hole that is
53 million light-years,
which is 318 quintillion miles away.
Now, that's an impressive
use of creativity and maths.
(light music continues)